ein wichtiger tipp punkt des
klimawandels ist jetzt schon erreicht
worden rund 70 jahre früher als die
klimawissenschaft vorausgesagt hatte und
kippt bedeutet dass hier ein prozess in
gang gekommen ist der den klimawandel
verstärkt und nicht mehr aufzuhalten ist
fix um science-fiction gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen heute klickst du
übrigens vom evangelischen kirchentag in
dortmund die deutsche bundesregierung
hat schwere schuld auf sich geladen sie
hat viel zu wenig gegen den klimawandel
unternommen und das obwohl sie über dem
weltklimarat umfassend über die
dramatische situation informiert ist es
wird sich in zukunft zeigen ob sich die
zuständigen politikerinnen und politiker
nicht irgendwann mal vor gericht
verantworten müssen
denn das ist tatsächlich massenmord was
jetzt geschieht und niemand kann sagen
sie oder er hätte es nicht gewusst jetzt
ist eine der schlimmsten katastrophen
eingetreten
die permafrostböden die normalerweise
ganzjährig gefroren sind trauen und das
in einem ausmaß wie es für 2090
vorhergesagt worden war dazu beigetragen
haben solche extremereignisse wie der
heiße sommer letztes jahr bei dem zum
ersten mal seit dem menschen das wetter
erfassen die gesamte nordhalbkugel warm
war die extreme aufheizung der letzten
jahre hat dazu geführt dass der
permafrostboden mit einer dramatischen
geschwindigkeit auftaucht in einigen
gebieten kanadas ist der boden
inzwischen stark abgetaut zwischen 2003
und 2016 ist der boden zum teil fast
einen meter abgesackt so ein
forschungsteam um die britische geologin
luise vorkasse und laut einer
langzeitstudie des
alfred-wegener-instituts aus bremerhaven
ist die bodentemperatur zwischen 2007
und 2016 im mittel um 0,3 grad celsius
an
der untergrund gibt somit nach und
gefährde die stabilität von straßen und
gebäuden zudem hat das ganze exklusive
folgen für uns alle und das im wahrsten
sinne des wortes denn durch das town der
permafrostböden wird gashydrat frei
das im boden eingelagert ist das gemisch
ist gefroren besteht aus methan und
wasser wenn es erwärmt wird explodiert
es in sibirien gab es bereits enorme
detonationen von denen riesige krater
zurück blieben aber auch das erdklima
muss darunter leiden denn das tauen des
permafrost setzt letztendlich
gigantische mengen an kohlendioxid und
methan frei die zu den langlebigen
treibhausgasen zählen und zur
erderwärmung beitragen konkret wird
durch das town der böden eine große
menge biomasse aus abgestorbenen
pflanzen frei die dann durch boden
bakterien zersetzt werden und bei diesem
prozess entsteht methan und kohlendioxid
und das nicht zu knapp nicht umsonst
wird das schmelzen des permafrosts in
der arktis als sogenannter kipp punkt
bezeichnet und der ist jetzt erreicht
rückkopplungseffekte im globalen
klimasystem also die am ende dafür
sorgen dass sich die erwärmung der erde
selbst verstärkt es ist also kein wunder
dass die sommertemperaturen im schnitt
so dramatisch steigen
der schmelzende permafrostboden
beschleunigt diesen prozess noch einmal
aber wir alle könnten ganz konkret etwas
dagegen tun alte autos mit
verbrennungsmotoren verschrotten lassen
und funktionierenden co2 sondern schnell
loswerden noch gibt es geld dafür
das wird sich in paar jahren ändern
stromanbieter wählen die ausschließlich
strom aus regenerativen energien
anbieten weniger fliegen und alles was
man an co2 verbraucht mit
klimazertifikaten ausgleichend für mich
sind das im monat beim ein co2 ausstoß
13 euro die ich zahle
das kann man doch verknusen und gebt
euren bundestagsabgeordneten auf die
nerven und fragt sie was sie dafür tun
damit deutschland die klimaziele für
2020 doch noch einhalten kann es ist zu
spät jetzt geht es darum das schlimmste
zu verhindern sollen wir einen eigenen
kanal zum thema umwelt und natur machen
schreibt sie in die kommentare
und falls ihr jemand kennt der immer
noch zweifel dem empfehle ich das video
klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker
endgültig widerlegt anklicken anschauen
und natürlich zum science fiction
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran